Oh my gosh, sorry, I just accidentally clicked on a video
that I don't know what this is.
Oh, okay.
Oh,
sorry, I was mid-editing my video.
I'm currently waiting on, I was editing the wolf among us.
Episode 3, I keep trying to export it and it keeps giving me
errors.
And then the one time it didn't give me an error.
I tried to upload it to YouTube and then it was stuck in
processing hell.
So I'm currently... And then I asked someone if they could
do it.
And then they said that they lost power or something.
So I was like, okay, I don't have much time to do this.
So I'm...
Truly, yeah, the curse among us.
It's a cursed video.
Ouch.
Bully Steiner for help?
Who do you think I asked?
I was like, is anybody available to do this?
And the person that they asked lost power.
So I am doing it myself.
But I am waiting for it.
Wait, how long is this going to take?
It's so frustrating because basically the reason I have to
upload or edit this episode is because I went to the
bathroom.
So it's in two parts.
And then also at the very beginning, during the recap, it
shows boobs.
I don't have to censor those.
Maybe I don't have to censor those.
It's hard.
Keep it in.
Keep it.
Oh no.
Yeah, but I still have to edit it so that it's one part.
I stopped recording so I could pee.
I promise to close my eyes.
Do you?
Right now it says it's uploading files.
I couldn't, I had to use an online editor.
I don't even know what this is.
I'm gonna get, I think I might download a virus.
Wouldn't that be so exciting if it were on stream, like at
ransomware?
I won't tell YouTube.
Now?
Getting a PC virus for the bit?
So fun, exciting.
Huh.
Imagine the content.
What?
What would...
Oh my gosh.
What if it's like saw?
What if it's like...
What if...
What if it's like a game of Saw?
That'd be so fun, though.
So that's why, sorry, that's why the game is not open at the
moment.
I don't have anything up.
Because I was editing the video!
Wait, hold on.
And then also, I've been getting pinged like a million
times.
Today has been a busy day, everybody.
How are you guys doing?
Wednesday!
Chilling.
It's mid-week.
It's hump day.
It's Wednesday.
It's Weirdo Wednesday.
Weirdo Wednesday!
Hump day!
Sleep, sleep to your stream.
Well, today should be a more chill stream, so...
Okay, hold on.
It's at 76%.
But this says uploading.
I wonder if this is also for exporting.
Let's see.
Hmm.
Matara Dono Alert.
That's why it sounded familiar to me.
Wait, one second.
Oh my gosh, I'm still getting pinged.
Hold on.
Happy Help Day.
Did you hear Nintendo and...
Yeah, the Star Fox remake out of nowhere.
Timulu!
Thank you so much for the farm gifted.
Thank you!
Future Beyond!
Thank you for the Hakusupa!
It's my birthday on Friday.
I wanted to shoot this early since you'll be traveling.
Sounds like it's a business trip.
But I hope you can still find time to get so much deserved
rest.
P.S.
If you do have a virus live on stream, Can we get a Steiner
reaction?
Why do you want his reaction?
Wait, should we have a webcam on that guy at all times?
So we can always just see if he's like...
Live British reaction?
Future Beyond Happy Birthday!
Happy Birthday!
I thought Star Fox is kind of crazy.
It looks really good.
I didn't actually watch the trailer, but I still...
I saw people screenshotting it.
They're really like, hey, hey, you guys should buy a Switch
too.
Hey, you guys should get a Switch too.
I'm not ready yet.
Steiner Feeder Cam.
That sounds a little...
You might want to rethink that one.
I don't think I like those words together.
Don't think...
Don't think so.
Just a truffle of British food.
It'll be like the deer cam.
But...
Very disturbing.
Or...
Recently, I've been on a hedgehog cam.
Hop on hedgehog cam.
But the hedgehogs are so inconsistent.
Sorry, the files are at 84%.
You might be like, why are you not playing the game?
It's because I need to keep an eye on the files.
The files.
I'm doing important things.
I'm doing important stuff.
Hedgehog cam!
You can make a don't-know alert that drops a bit more kibble
into its pool.
You're a soon...
Oh, sorry, I had notice turned off, sorry.
No, no, thank you!
Testing 1, 2, 3, boo testing.
Boo.
I'm a certified PC tech if you need one.
Also, Nintendo announced Switch 2 Pokemon Pokopiya Bundle.
They did!
Wait, that might be worth...
I don't...
The thing is, is I want to play Pokopiya so bad, but I don't
feel like I have the time to right now.
So it would just gather dust.
But at the same...
Hot dog!
Flying for the first time since watching you, the combo of
Apiju's Oshikata's top gut was so good!
I'm glad you liked the Yuzu!
Yumi!
Which it did let you personally have convinced me to spend
$190.
is on Logitech's flight stick for the upcoming Ace Combat.
Don't send me.
Money then, after spending so much.
I mean, though, I won't be able to watch streams for about a
week because I'm going to New York to get a surgery done on
my head this weekend.
Wireson!
I was supposed to have this surgery done over two years ago,
but I did it for reasons.
Wireson, good luck!
won't be streaming for a week so you're as soon as i'm back
you're back and then we'll all be together again nothing
will even nothing will even happen these vids were in my
game i immensely thought of you hope your customers lives
and gus thank you thank you for the codes thank you uh it
works great my supah got ignored hi me though hi nolo what
i'm Sorry, I don't think I saw it.
Sorry, sometimes I miss...
Sometimes I miss...
I don't know.
But thank you.
Minto confirmed doing wires on surgery.
Yes, that's me.
I do have a doctor.
Is Nimi your nurse?
Call me...
Doc.
What do I...
Hi Oshi, can I get hit with good energy?
I'm in a riding contest and I came in third place.
I'm advancing next round!
5,000 entered, 890 left.
Whoa!
Ooh, crunch!
Wait.
Do you need the good energy?
Because that's already such a good energy!
Congratulations!
Okay, files are at 92%.
Hold
on, uh, let me type so that everyone.
Okie dokie.
By the way, I've only seen Wolf Among Us 1, 2, 4, and 5
keep...
I know, I know.
What do you think the files are?
Finally hit two years.
Thank you, Baki!
Thank you, thank you.
The files are at 93%.
I wanted to get it done as soon as possible Because I didn't
want to have to keep Explaining and explaining and
explaining Honestly, I should just private them until I
Until I Uh Think about the editors I am the editor What are
you talking about?
It's me!
I'm a one ghost team!
I was like you!
I'm excited for more chill, rewinding and retroing this
evening Yeah!
I'm chilling with some herbal mint tea watching Oh, I forgot
to refill my tea.
I was so busy.
I was so busy with the file.
The files.
Even though this stream series is super relaxing, you are
the best rental store manager.
Thank you.
I'm gonna put this on the background while doing work.
Good luck with your trip next week.
Thank you, Fistov.
Thank you.
Would I crash out in front of a KFC?
I don't think you'll find me in front of a KFC.
I don't know.
I've, I think I, actually, I can count a number of KFCs.
on my hand that I've been to wait, I forgot to say the part
I can count the number of KFCs on my hand that I've been to
aren't they good in Japan?
I don't think it's necessarily different in Japan I think it
just has like a reputation for for being Christmas food I
Not even for Christmas?
No, I don't have it for Christmas.
Minto makes puppets.
Oh, do you guys, while we wait, do you guys want to see
Vicky Puppet?
I finished it.
Well, um, well, actually, I still need to do the back.
Hold on, wait one second, sorry.
There's so much happening.
There's so...
Okay, picture.
Puppets.
Ow!
I'm throwing my phone.
Oh, wait, I already uploaded this film.
Whatever.
Um.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Da-da.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I got it.
Look at them!
Us three!
Thanks for the good time I was here, Blake.
Thank you!
Aren't they so cute?
Yeah.
That three of us!
MVP!
Yeah.
I do have to finish the back.
I feel like My hair on mine, it looks more muddy in the
photo than it does in real life.
But unfortunately, it is a little icky like that.
But I feel like I got better.
I kind of reached my stride once I started with VB and
Vicky.
That's kind of why I wanted to do mine first.
But yeah, yeah, y'all.
And then I accidentally made Vicky a little small.
Oopsie.
Yeah, I got all warmed up.
But I still have to do...
I finished Phoebe, her back of her outfit.
But I still need to do the back of mine and the back of
Vicky's.
But yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, please don't emote spam.
Thank you.
Accidentally nerfed.
No, no, I don't mean I made her boobs too small.
I made her like her head too small.
I made her...
I actually also realized...
I hope that these fit...
You know...
I guess they only need to fit my hand.
I guess.
Probably.
They're so cute.
All the temptation to go to Fandom It just to win them is
very strong.
Hmm?
I mean...
That sounds very confident.
Nixie, you think that you will win them, huh?
That's some confidence.
But yeah, they're made for ghost hands.
Oops, my bad.
I even tried to make Vicky, I even like went extra big.
And then I tried it and I was like, oh no.
Good thing I went extra big because it's so small.
whoopsie but yeah my my puppets my hand puppets are they're
popping off baby you did incredible with these cute puppets
i adore the polka dot gems thanks baby's braids and minto
sleeve folds lovely details thank you pisto yeah i do i i
was thinking i should have made i should have folded my
sleeve down a little bit more but what it is.
You know, I'm just being a perfectionist now.
Let me check the files.
My video is too long.
What do you mean?
It's whatever this website I use wants me to pay.
I
can't...
I can't...
Um...
Maybe I can download a video editor instead.
Uh, what's...
Oh, there's that free one.
Um...
Uh...
I've never used Da Vinci, though.
I don't know it.
Cap cut?
I thought that's only TikTok.
Right.
Da Vinci?
never use it.
Is it easy to use?
Da Vinci.
I'm hoping that it's not an issue with the recording itself.
That's what I'm really nervous about.
Because I don't know why else it would I would keep getting
error for exporting each time otherwise.
Let
me try downloading this.
This turns into a video editing stream?
Where's the download button?
Tell me how to download your product.
I don't care about what it does.
Tell me how to download it.
Oh, free download.
Wait.
Download.
Okay.
No, I don't want to put...
No, I don't want to register.
No.
No, I don't want to put in my address.
Okay.
that's not an option.
Hmm, let's see.
Hmm.
Oh, they don't check?
Okay.
My phone number is one, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine.
And now I live in I live in I live in Kentucky.
What do you mean my email is not valid?
Register and download?
Oh, nice.
It worked.
Who knew you could live at Lane?
Actually, I didn't even put Lane.
I just put in Kentucky.
Also, don't call my phone number.
It's very important.
Very important phone number.
I can't change it.
It has a direct line.
A direct line.
I can call.
The cool dead people.
I'm trying to reach you about your car's extended warranty.
Sorry to the poor sap that lives on this street.
And also...
Also...
um has that phone number
yeah alright okay I'm gonna install this now
oh is it gonna work hello uh oh wait my computer froze uh
guys can you see me?
am I still alive?
hello
Oh, what is this?
Window dialogue not responding.
Oh, I see you guys.
Um, hmm.
Uh-oh.
Uh.
I really...
I just need to do this now because I'm not gonna have time.
We have a den set to meeting tonight.
I won't have time afterwards.
The virus!
Oh my gosh, I'm playing saw!
Wait, if I...
Oh.
Okay.
We're fine.
The music stopped at such a suspicious time.
Okay, let's try that again.
Open.
Da Vinci Resolve.
EXE.
Uh-oh, it froze again.
Oh, no, it's extracting!
It's extracting!
Okay, never mind, just kidding.
We're fine.
It worked.
Yes.
Hmm.
No, I don't want any of this.
Window sound jump scare.
Are you scared?
Do you need me to hold your hand?
Are you okay?
Okay, it's installing.
It's installing Do not put Do not download a computer virus
Well I have no other choice I have to I have to download
this Because the put my Windows Edit or Adobe Is stupid I'm
downloading the virus I'm doing I'm downloading densetsu
.exe.
Execute.
I'm downloading RAM.
They promised me more RAM.
There were three girls.
They said, if you download
densetsu.exe.
We will give you...
Oh, installation complete.
We will give you more RAM.
And that's like kind of insane of an offer.
These days.
These days, anybody offering RAM?
More RAM in this economy?
Alright, I'm opening D'Vinci Resolve.
Continue.
Great, you're almost there.
Quick setup.
Yeah, I'm in a hurry.
Okay, thank you.
Goodbye.
Continue.
Oh.
Select your keyboard.
Oh, they have a Premiere keyboard.
Oh, that's what I use.
You wouldn't...
Don't...
Wait, what's wrong with me?
Download a touch frame.
What's wrong with me?
You would not dog.
Alright.
You guys might hear me editing this a little bit.
Wait, why is this thing so slow?
Oh my gosh, wait, what's the timeline?
Wait, how do I use this?
Change?
I don't know.
Okay.
It's not very intuitive.
I would install the density toolbar for Internet Explorer.
Um, do you mean...
Microsoft Edge?
Oh, wait, which one's part one?
This is part one.
Wait, what is the timeline?
Or how do I edit it?
Uh...
Wait, why is it starting at one minute in?
Wait, huh?
I'm so confused.
Oh, I don't think I like this program.
This is my first super chat I wanted to say Domenky.
Brandon, thank you!
Da Vinci.
Baby, Kory, thank you so much for the park, gifted!
Wait, can I...
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna share this thing.
Everybody help me out.
Da Vinci resolve.
Okay, help me out here.
Okay, why so...
Why is...
does it start all the way like it's at one minute also it
won't let me scroll is this not the timeline is this the
timeline oh here we go oh that's me i'm talking here i'll
show you the boobs that i'm trying to censor out oh
it's like right here now i need to put snake in
he needs to go like right there but why does it start at one
minute i'm so confused okay hold on Oh.
Oh, there they are.
Okay, now don't look.
Promise me you're closing your eyes right now.
Wait, how do I move?
How do I edit this here?
Uh-oh, wait.
Okay, wait.
Hold on.
Wait, how do I...
How do I move Snake?
Why can't I move him where I need him to be?
I don't think I like this program.
Why is it so difficult to use?
Steiner is trying to tell you he assigned a second editor
for this so you don't have to do it.
Oh, you did?
Oh, I have a ping.
We have someone working on it.
You can just stream.
It'll be...
He's yelling at me in all caps.
Steiner, stop yelling.
I'm sensitive.
You are in the cut section.
One tab over on the bottom, you can move to the cut section.
Wait, I'm in the cut section.
One tab over?
Where?
Well, now I'm learning DaVinci Resolve, okay?
And look, I'm giving my everybody a show.
Look at her go.
Well, she starts like...
He starts doing that too.
Now how do I censor all of that?
How do I move Snake?
Let's see.
The very bottom?
Oh, I see it!
Oh, okay, okay.
Edit.
Oh!
Wait, where'd Snake go?
Uh-oh.
We lost him?
We lost him in the...
Oh, there he is.
He's here.
Come here, Snake.
Snake, I need you to move.
Snake, I need you to move around.
Snake, I need to be able to move you.
Snake!
Wait, did I only... Oh, yeah.
This is part one.
I need part two.
Here's part two.
There we go.
And I said, I went to the party.
My Kamiyoshi is truly fearless.
What do you mean?
All right, Snake.
Do your thing.
Wait, is it even...
Let's see.
When does it start?
He just appears out of nowhere.
I mean, this is good enough, right?
Maybe.
The bottom left of that window is the transform.
Bottom left of the window.
window you
need to a snake is selected he's selected he's selected
unless i move him here uh uh oh wait where'd he go there he
is okay uh chat there's so many windows i know bottom left
under the video screen which video which video which video
This one?
Oh!
Oh my god, progress.
We'll get it framed perfect, don't worry.
Don't worry, don't worry, you worry, your pretty little
head.
Alright, she's dancing, she's dancing.
Okay, he looks like a poster on her wall.
There we go!
Okie dokie!
Oh my gosh, I'm learning!
I'm learning DaVinci Resolve!
DaVinci...
Yippee!
Okay, that's all I needed to do!
Love learning DaVinci with DaVinci.
Yippee!
Thank you, everybody!
Why is this the transform tool?
It's so strange.
Aww.
Oh, you can't see it, but it says transform and crop.
Dynamic zoom.
Annotations.
Okay, now I save this.
Export project.
Oh, no.
That's, it saves it as a drip file.
That's crazy.
Export timeline.
Why is it, what is a DRT file?
What the heck?
Uh, uh, oh.
You're us.
Congrats, you are now a clipper.
How to render it from the rocket ship.
Oh, deliver.
Okay, I see it at the bottom.
Nice.
Okay.
And add to render queue.
Okay, videos.
Yeah, save.
Insufficient storage.
What?
That's not true at all.
It might be true.
Wait.
It's true!
It's true, maybe that's why I kept getting errors.
Oh my gosh, this is why I downloaded Densetsu.exe!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna- I can- it's okay.
I have a SSD.
It's called Snake.
More storage.
I already downloaded it.
Okay.
Save to Snake.
My S drive.
Save.
Add to render queue.
Oh!
The job won!
Wait, do I have to do anything else?
Or is it already on it?
Is it working?
How do I know if it's rendering?
Wait, hold on.
You have to start the job.
Where does the start button?
render queue render all wait pencil how do i start it render
all okay job one is being edited it is update the job oh
there she goes there she goes
40 minutes remaining why does it take so long Holy cow.
We could watch.
What's she yapping about?
Oh, I'm reading the fables.
Can I stop it from exposing me?
Crooked and vile.
You can minimize it.
Oh, we're at, we have 2% remaining.
Now I think we're at 2%.
I remember all of this.
Look at her goal.
Oh, it worked!
Snake!
Don't worry, I edited it in other fun ways in the actual
episode.
Minkee Resolve.
No, wait.
I don't want you guys to see my choices.
That's no fun.
Oh, my gosh.
This is so great, though.
Okay.
We'll get rid of it.
We'll play the game now.
We'll play the game.
No, no spoilers.
Let's retro rewind, everybody.
Oh, my gosh.
I possessed somebody that got Papa John.
and I forget that Papa John's absolutely makes me sick.
I feel so icky.
Don't eat Papa John's, everybody.
Even if it is delicious.
All right, hold on.
I gotta, all right, let's capture the game now.
Retro rebuy is gonna be really big.
And then I make it small.
Nice.
The coupons are tempting.
Oh, you're so right, though.
I know I love their garlic sauce.
It's so good.
Papa John's is gross, but I also kind of like it.
Yeah.
But don't do it.
It might be tempting, but don't.
Don't try it.
Don't think about it.
Their sauce is really yummy.
I love the garlic butter.
I mean, I'm a garlic girl.
I don't eat anything garlic.
2095?
No, we're in the 90s, no.
It's been a minute since we last played.
20 days ago.
That's almost a whole month.
Oh, dogs and dinos.
I missed you.
Our place is so awesome.
That's the game version.
Oh.
Hello.
Hey, Ryan.
Long time.
No see.
Uh, wait.
Oh, keep working.
Usually he says don't talk to me until I've had my coffee.
Wait, he didn't even clock in.
Wait.
Did they update the game or something?
I wonder.
Did they update the game so that he doesn't...
He forgot to clot...
Thanks for the free labor, Ryan.
I woo!
Uh, oh, are you curious about this location?
Look at all our potential customers just wandering away.
Before we do anything...
Oh, we did everything.
Wait, let's check the calendar.
It's Halloween.
and we have no new movies we got the Galactica Rebellion oh
my gosh I made a 4th made a 4th it's May the 6th oh wow open
sign is turned inside yeah because we're close silly what
are you talking about silly oh wait oh I thought you meant
it was like a physical thing that we flip around the time
for work the time for video work gave me exactly the time i
needed to get home and make dinner yay do i go thank you
shipmate is in for a treat oh you are in for a treat with
this one this one's really good okay our place is looking
cute as Heck, we don't have that many horror.
Everybody's been renting them out, but that's okay.
I think we can start up.
I think we can go.
Oh, let me.
Everybody, everybody.
Come one, come all.
Come to the store.
Why is everybody upset about it?
Oh, whoa.
Deal?
Oh.
No, you're coming in.
Hot dog.
I can eat.
Wait, no, don't leave.
Oh, okay.
You don't care.
Oh, she has blankets so fun.
Thank you.
Also, not Minky working Ryan for free.
Hey.
He loves me so much.
He would work for free.
Don't you, Ryan?
Every Ryan in chat say yes.
I'm paying you in free snacks.
Isaac is the one that got the shipmate.
Is him for a treat?
Oh.
That's why they call you Isaac.
What do you want?
Oh my goodness, hold on.
I'm looking for an adult film.
It's about a male T-Rex that gets pregnant by another male
T-Rex.
And also his two T-Rex friends help him get enough money to
raise the baby.
And then they help with the delivery.
It's very rare.
Do you have it?
I have every adult T-Rex film you could ever imagine.
In fact, the ones that I've produced as well.
I'm charging you the fee.
Yeah, you better be sorry.
What do you want?
I rented a movie last week and it was brutally bad.
I need something that actually entertains me.
A good movie.
Dr. Lane's chosen hag, everybody says it's all the rage.
Is that last one a bit?
I've never done a bit ever.
What's a bit?
Reserved.
A bit?
You need some insect repellent or something?
Yeah, I'm always serious.
Alright, what?
I'm gonna kill you.
Where's my gun?
Get him in the booty hole.
How dare he do that to my... to my stuff?
Oh my gosh.
Um, one second.
Wait, he reserved the shipmate!
That was Isaac!
You guys...
Isaac might be the worst ever.
Hi.
Sorry if your name is Isaac.
I hope you're having a great day.
Thank you, Kapoor!
You too!
Ryan's payment is the joy of seeing you every day.
Who needs money anyway?
Guys, is Ryan one of us?
The Blazing Enchanter.
Meow meow.
The way she looks at me is she pays me money.
Wow, we're banning him from the store.
Dang, this lady is...
She's so thick.
Like, her booty...
Look at the way the basket hugs her.
Wow.
It's been so long since the last stream that I've been...
managed to unlock all expansions and completed a year.
Should I spoil what happens?
No!
No spoilers?
I don't know, though.
We'll see how um, you know, I could just kind of keep this
game on forever like in the back of like a sort of like a,
oh, I need a game to play this week.
Oh, I'll do retro rewind.
But, you know, these types of games can be tough if it's
just like, oh, I don't know how long I could stream.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Am I making sense?
Especially with how my backlog is.
I have so many games.
It is a good Zatsu game, though, no?
It's also just kind of...
It's one of those games.
Even when I watch people play this game, I feel like I'm
captivated by it.
Like, I can't stop watching.
I'm just, like, watching the streamer Run around.
Stiff PC.
Watching streamer run around and put away things and do
things.
It just like tickles a fancy for me.
Does it do that for anybody else?
Oh.
Hello?
Yes.
Christmas movies.
Oh, that's horror.
Oh.
Ma'am, you're standing right next to it.
Wow.
Video editing class gave me time to finish my workout.
Good job, Super Lenovo!
I can't speak today.
Super, super liminal.
Thanks for co-working.
And keeping me motivated now, full attention.
Aw, thanks.
Does it tickle our fancy?
A bit.
Her.
Did he just go her at me?
No, no, don't leave.
Don't leave.
potential customers hmm what else can we even unlock I
wonder if what else has been like maybe more shelving?
No?
More decorations?
What?
What has been what has been up what has been added?
It's like they haven't updated the game at all
horror movie for the big storm oh yeah i got you i got i got
a scary sailor in the tent terrifying
let's see who else can we bring in
we yarn for the tape mines i'm glad you guys sometimes i'm
always like well you know like play what I want to but at
the same time I try to be like oh you know is this a good
stream game or not but you know I still do play what I want
otherwise it's like you know if I don't like what I'm
playing it's not gonna be fun but then when you guys also
like it I'm so like I knew you guys were my abus you know
I'm like oh Why you guys give me...
Wow!
So true.
Yeah, so true.
It's so true.
Oh, oops.
Metal Gear Moment.
How is that a Metal Gear Moment?
We've been curated.
To my silly simulation simulation game tastes.
Some of it...
Yes, someone made the mods!
The Ibu mods!
I was so caught up in everything today.
I meant to add it.
I'm so sorry.
Well, then, you know what?
That's a reason for us to play again.
So I should have done it while I was waiting for the files.
Just like hanging out with you.
Thank you.
I know you mainly stock VHS mint, but do you have any boo
rays?
I wouldn't have had enough storage.
I think it's honestly because...
Hello?
Because I recorded stuff.
I need to go through and...
I need to go through and delete them.
The Ibu mods are all done and shouldn't be more than 2-3
minutes to install.
Just restart after they're installed.
How do I...
How do I install them?
I do want to.
I want them.
Yes?
Cupcake brain implants?
Right here.
Ah!
Nexus mod.
Okay, that's probably something I have to download, no?
I want to do it.
Hold on.
Let's finish the day and then I'll do it.
This is the smallest bill I have.
It's a website.
Oh, okay.
Download the mod files.
Oh, easy!
Okay, cool.
Hehehehe hehehehe heard that video files take up a lot of
space.
Yeah, they can and then you know I have five files that are
About an hour and a half each one two hours so You know it's
gonna It's definitely gonna take up money.
Wow our clearance bin is almost empty People have been going
great.
What the where did all that did we lose another customer?
Never heard of Nexus mods truly not a Skyrim player.
Oh, you know me.
I say that I'm Skyrim's number one fan.
And I've always said that.
Besides, game rentals, the dev roadmap includes selling VIP
membership, so there seems to be a bunch of new content
coming.
Oh, cool.
Do you see that, Zach?
That person just pushed their VHS tapes all over the floor.
Amazing.
How people are just so careless and selfish.
then why haven't you played skyrim yet i'm i'm literally i i
live skyrim i don't play it i climb mountains i fight bears
and i do quests side quests even i've done every quest you
can ever think of i don't believe it you're oh she born what
does that mean skyrim was based off of my afterlife actually
yeah it's an everyday thing for me the cotton candy do you
like MGS or Skyrim more I have to keep to the bit Skyrim
taking the long road today Ryan hmm working hard or hardly
working hello hi oh he does need to punch his time card he
forgot yesterday he's a little mad about it that had to hurt
you comically get knocked into the sky by giants all the
time I'm you know my neighbor is a giant or something let's
buy cotton candy
noise can we when can we buy a second employee hi Ryan let's
see oh we only have two people no one is applying for my
store even though it's business is booming you can't buy
people so says you we have they have prices now next to
their names.
She has a point.
Let's save and then I go to Nexus mod.
Sorry, I feel like the stream is everywhere today.
But also I can check on my export.
Tell me, Minky, what you think about the storm cloaks?
This is a trick question.
You know I've never seen Star Wars, so stop asking.
Oh wow, it only says 20 minutes remaining.
Awesome.
Alright, Nexus Mods.
Oh, browse all mods.
I'm gonna search mayonnaise recipe.
No, um, search.
Um, how do I search?
What do I even think?
search uh mint that's me i'm getting fallout cyberpunk mint
car oh retro rewind search ibu ibu decoration wait how do i
get this now okay hold on replaces the medieval armor
decoration with ibu okay cute okay Open the game install
folder.
I gotta go to Steam.
Then it's Star Wars and Mambu!
Watch along!
I feel like at this point we must because it's been brought
up so many times.
Retro.
Retro rewind.
Uh, blah blah blah.
Wait, hold on.
Uh, where are you?
Files.
Did I have it?
Open the...
Hmm.
Wait a second.
Wait, I have to download this first.
Download.
Slow download.
I have to have an account?
No!
Okay.
Login.
Or register.
Okay.
Verify email.
I gotta go to my email.
I have a verification code.
Copy and paste and verify my email.
Oh gosh.
I just made my password.
Oh my gosh.
No, I didn't.
Okay, I'm gonna use my password manager for this.
I don't feel like memorizing it.
Okay.
Alright, do your thing.
Generate a password.
Yeah.
Auto fail?
Oh, oh!
Nice!
Save.
Sign.
I'll create an account.
Free.
With that happy revenge of the sixth!
Oh!
Shut up!
New to modding.
Select a game you would have mod.
Retro Rewind.
Guys, I'm so up on my modding it.
I'm so...
You guys...
Ouch!
You guys gotta get on my level with my modding skills.
I'm out here doing retro Rewind.
Yeah, baby.
This is a technology learning.
streaming stream I actually though actually okay let's see
go back to the mod how do I do this okay wait I need to open
the folders okay manage browse local files okay I got that
open the zip and drag the contents okay opening the zip zip
zip zippity do zip zippity zip zippity Zip, zip, zip, zip,
zup, zup, zup, zup, zup, zup, zup, zup, zup.
Right there.
And move.
Okay.
Hi there, Domenky Resolver.
Steiner says, hello, Mint.
The file is ready and exported.
Wait, no way.
Well, how are you?
How is...
How is everybody...
How are you getting this information from him?
How are you guys talking to him?
Anyways, let's, uh...
Oh, thank you!
You also sent me this.
I'll just...
He sent me this.
I'll show you.
Oh, no.
Oh, my goodness.
No, stop it, stop.
Look at this image he did.
You guys wanted the live Steiner reaction.
There it is.
Imagine he is just in a Discord call bitchin.
That guy's got, if he's doing that, he's got too much time
on his hands.
I'm not keeping him busy enough.
Shindobi, thank you so much for the five gifted.
I'm going to try uploading, sorry, while we, okay.
Now I'm going to upload the episode and see if it goes
through.
then then we can play the game everybody this is a game
stream this is a game stream i promise you please please
please no we are playing a game today download download
anyway
wait well i have okay it's six gigs i have that much i have
four 14.
We're almost there.
You don't believe me.
What can I do to convince you?
What can I do to convince you of my very real promise that
we are playing a game today?
Wait, is it downloading?
Yes.
Okay, I have to download the video first.
And that's going to be another minute.
um let's see i'm gonna title this one um i'm gonna title
this one mr toads number one fan
mr toads i don't even know if he's in this episode number
one fan what do you mean you're managing videos this is
totally on the level you're so right i thought i joined late
but i'm we're just getting started it's been over an hour
and i played one day of the game coming in a bit late
something happened to retro rewind no no it's okay credit to
weeping for the meme steinerson he doesn't even credit the
people that make the stuff that he sends to me you guys
doesn't even credit them here's just in case the vod gets
nuked because of the oh the chiku because of a chiku b pixel
ah thanks it wasn't just the censoring though it was also
the fact that i needed to you know um uh put the stitch them
together you know okay upload video uploading uh wolf among
us funny snake censored got mp4 with the title bada bing
bada boom la-la-ling la-l-l-u with my episode 3 thumbnail
boom boom boom public set as premiere oh shoot wait what day
is this for this is 1 to the 11th I think 7 p.m.
schedule
Let me double check.
Yuppie!
Let's play the game.
What a day.
Retro rewind.
Wait.
And
the game will appear now.
Yuppie!
Gumball peeping through the keyhole.
What is it?
For those who sent codes earlier, I think it was just one of
you so far.
Wait, episode 3 would be on the 12th?
Wait, did I put it in wrong?
One second.
Oh my gosh.
No, episode 4 is the 12th.
Nine.
Yeah.
I just got one guide for real.
Gumball is wild.
Gunball peeping through the keyhole.
Milan!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
All right.
Last played today.
And hopefully this worked.
Let's see.
How much is the armor?
Hopefully it's not too expensive.
Decorations?
I'm buying it.
Why did I do it wrong?
The war nutcrackers.
What did I do wrong?
I bought this for nothing.
Check settings for mods.
Let me see.
Options.
Censored adult film.
I would never...
Video?
I don't see anything about the mods.
Hmm.
I didn't see it when I pressed B.
It wouldn't let me change anything on it.
Oh, Aibu!
Aibu.
Oh well, I tried.
Hmm.
I did try.
All right.
Let's, uh...
My goodness.
Yes?
What do you want?
My wife just told me she felt pressured to buy snacks by
your staff.
What kind of video store business are you running?
Not my problem.
I missed a part where that was my problem.
Oh, our new movies are back.
Gimme, gimme, gimme.
Must have installed it in the wrong place.
Check the visual aid in the images tab.
Okay.
I'll try it.
I put it in the folder.
Oh, Corona, thank you so much for the skews.
Thank you.
Yes.
Oh my god, the dogs out there are loud.
What's going on out here?
You?
He said, sorry for the noise.
Wait, Ryan, I'm gonna make you do this.
Oh, Ryan.
Return station, now!
I'm gonna let him do this while I go get some water.
I'll be right back.
Oh, sorry, I'm almost...
How is Ryan doing?
Are you guys making sure that he's up to stuff?
Welcome back, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
New releases, we'll go put these away.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh, he's slow.
Let's see.
What do we have coming?
Oh, we don't know anything.
Wait, why can't we see a win- Tomorrow's gonna be winter?
No, heckin' way.
I know he's all dressed up.
It's so cute.
I wonder what I'm wearing for Halloween.
Oh, while he's doing it, I can do stuff too.
Yeah.
Oh, dang it.
Don't look, Ryan.
Don't look.
I'm doing your job.
Winter in May.
Um, actually, it's Christmas in July.
We'll let him get back to it.
We'll put our dramas up.
okay i can try once we're done with this i'll try fixing the
mod um i know but i do actually want to play the game so if
i don't get it working this time then we will just you know
have it for uh another time sorry i don't want to like just
be troubleshooting the entire stream
But obviously I want to have...
Have...
The modes.
We can let him do the rest.
Horror, horror, horror, horror, horror, horror, horror.
Game ago.
Yeah, we need to be gaming!
Which do you guys prefer?
I don't know.
I think I actually like having him on the register.
Wait.
No, never mind.
Keep working.
I like having him on the register and me being able to go
get new customers and running around.
I think he's the best.
All right, Ryan.
I'm assigning you to checkout.
And we're about to open up, buddy.
Big smiles.
Register does seem a little stagnant.
Yeah.
All right, we're saving.
And I am...
All right, we're going to do this one last time.
One last time.
Okay.
In the images tab.
Let me see.
Nope, that's exactly what I did.
For reference.
Yeah, I did exactly that.
For...
though wait
I'll double check maybe this maybe it's like this
maybe maybe I messed it up a little bit maybe like that
maybe but also there was some other mods weren't there let
me double check uh
And let me search Mint Fanto.
The Junior Mintz.
And...
Download.
Slow download.
You have a childhood movie you watched over and over.
My brother and I were talking about ours the other day.
The Iron Giant.
You know I've never seen the Iron Giant.
But mine was Nightmare Before Christmas.
I was crazy.
Let me see.
Nola, thank you!
So, my first trip with that, I took part in the last Retro
Rewind stream, where you were kind of dancing before
unmuting, and I put it in my own...
Wait, and I put it in my own game?
I tweeted a video of it.
What the heck?
Thank you!
That's so funny.
Let's see.
Oh, here we go.
Download.
download okay yeah I watched so much nightmare before
Christmas that my mom would be like turn that movie off
please I'm sick of it oops oops sorry mom sorry all right
extract la la la la la la la la move to file okay and then
the extract okay move oh move to file there we go okay
hopefully hopefully now we're good all right let's play the
game retro back to game did you continue watching of course
i did of course i did
beggar in his grasp.
Fingies crossed, everybody.
Fingies crossed.
I did it right!
Ew!
Do I have that one?
I don't know.
Let's check.
Let's see.
Let's check some of the skews you guys have sent me.
Please fix my leaky zombie.
It's kind of, why are the adult movies so expensive?
Let's see, we got this one.
Hot dog peeping through the keyhole!
We'll buy that.
Sausage team, the last hope!
Okay, I don't have so much money, so I gotta be careful.
Explosive sausage.
Very good.
gripping my mushroom
the lady in my pants oh this one is okay this one's not so
expensive we can get that one okay nice hot dog peeping
through the keyhole now everybody has been asking for this
one so I'm really glad we got it in stock now lady in my
pants and sausage achieve.
I love the hot dog that's like on this guy's face.
Front and center, baby.
Okay.
Ryan, you good?
Wait, what happened to your mask?
No, it's still Halloween.
No!
Aw, we lost him.
Hello, welcome.
Hello.
Come, come, come, come.
Yes, come to my...
Come to my video store.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Don't leave.
Yes.
She has a stash again.
How did he grow that so fast?
Hi.
What would you like?
Oh.
Galactic Rebellion.
Oh, people returned a ton.
Did you hear all that?
Hmm.
award nutcrackers.
The music is so scary.
Dang it.
I'll take it.
I'm trying to get... I try to get like two genres at a time.
I mess up sometimes though.
Oh yes.
Alright.
Science fiction.
Ooh.
Harbour?
Harbour, harbour, harbour, action.
Nice.
Alright.
Business is booming, you guys.
This is crazy.
I think we could do this.
We can stay open forever.
And ever and ever and ever and ever.
Does everybody like the new decoration?
so cool i agree bad dreams on mel road
he's so cute i know he fits so well like a like the mascot
the store mascot is perfect no wait that was a rare one even
You bastards!
Fantasy.
Action.
I'm gonna have to start getting new shelves again soon.
Fantasy, Christmas...
Christmas Eve with my letters.
Santa Claus looks absolutely terrifying.
Probably should be on the horror shelf.
I got on top of you!
He's like, good job, champ.
I'm proud of you.
Also?
Hi.
Wrong game, Minto.
He was in the other simulator.
What did it mean?
Officer Bloodbath.
That sounds like a real movie title.
Okay.
Let's go see if we can get more people in.
Hmm.
Yes.
Come to my store.
You love movies.
Beam.
You love movies so much.
You.
Not interested.
What if I... What if I look at you like this?
You love movies.
You.
You wouldn't deny small business, would you?
Oh.
Yeah?
A horror movie.
There you go.
It's working.
Vampires and werewolves don't scare me.
Could you suggest an actual horror movie that is scary?
All right, Samantha.
Hmm.
What about...
Hag on death row.
Poor customer waiting.
No, they're not waiting that long.
They're not waiting that long.
Yeah.
You love movies.
Oops, sorry.
Ooh.
Yeah.
She loves movies.
You love movies.
Movies will make you grow hair.
No, no, please.
yeah it will it will i promise what would a ghost ever lie
to you
hi oh hello my film class is talking about all these
classics and i'm totally lost would you help broaden my old
my movie knowledge and suggest an old film
How about keeping my gum machine oiled up?
He appreciates it.
Everyone in your class will want to hear you talk about
that.
I would sign up for that class.
Wouldn't you guys?
Everybody signs up for that one probably.
A vintage classic.
Probably Jackie Chan might be in that one.
Do you know Jackie Chan was in a porno?
Oh, romance.
Action.
Inheriting the organ.
Oh, drama.
Oh, this is horror.
I'm not lying.
Look it up.
This?
Galactic Rebellion.
There you go.
Wow.
I'm so from Adolf Hill Facts.
I mean, everybody's got to get their star, you know.
Everybody's got to get their star.
Hoorah.
Look at all these.
Look at this.
I'm keeping the shelves stocked, baby.
How did you start?
Well?
Oh, who are you?
Well, you know, for me, it all started with a certain
untimely death.
Where are all the trick-or-treaters?
Are you coming in anyway?
Hey.
Oh, okay.
Ghost videos.
Yeah, you could find me on spooky ghost videos on e-bombs
world.
I remember There was one time I was having a sleepover with
my friend And we were watching ghost videos on On E-Bomb's
world It's stuck in my brain Until this day Because I was
like This is the scary Will I ever be as scary of a ghost As
As these ghosts.
I thought it was like, I was like, dang.
These ghosts are like crazy scary.
Um, oh, she's asking for... Does anyone ask for cotton
candy?
I want to try it.
Oh.
Oh, this looks awesome.
You want some, Ryan?
This one's on the house.
unlocked.
I was too busy on Neopeds?
Okay, but true.
I was also on Neopeds a lot.
Alright, everybody.
It's midnight, please.
You need to pay the fee.
I'll take that.
Get out of my sight.
Happy Halloween!
For me, it was new grounds.
I was also on new grounds i was on i actually did not go on
e-bombs world very much i went on what was it albino black
sheep more but like on e-bombs world i feel like it had like
the like some of the classic like there was like the the
like the ultimate showdown of ultimate
but albino black sheep had like a badger badger and magical
trevor a blast from the past
i was really obsessed with the lions in kenya oh my gosh i
know
I guess we should just get rid of Keg and Moonbase.
Oh, but it was a shiny.
Terrible.
All of these people are terrible.
Oh, Weevil stuff.
Oh, wait, maybe that's where I watched them.
You're right.
Maybe I'm getting them all confused.
Oh, my gosh.
Maybe I think you're right, actually.
Wait, what was that an albino black sheet?
I don't remember.
Winter!
Ooh, it's nasty out.
It's raining.
It's pouring.
Oh my gosh.
Ryan, we're gonna get flooded in.
Come on, come on.
Oh yeah, I love the Homestar Runner.
Yeah, oh wow, our movies are all gone.
Our clearance movies, it's totally empty.
I wonder if there was, okay, there was, uh...
Mom, I'm in the game!
Are you, are you Leonardo DiCaprio pointing right now?
There was some other...
Oh, I got the...
Oh, it was the...
It was the chocolates, that's right.
Let's, uh...
Let's see.
That's me!
Wait, can I...
Only the same kind of snack can be...
Okay.
That's me!
Creamy mint and pure chocolate.
Mmm.
Okay, we will stock up on the other stuff, though.
Crunchyzilla.
And the Freddy's.
Or dino gummies.
And Freddy's.
Dino gummies.
Alright, very good, very good.
That's a me!
Oh, we're like right next to each other.
Oh, can you start a return station?
I should have done that earlier, my bad.
Oh yeah, let's check what we've got.
What a sad day.
Blue Monday, known as the most depressing day of the year.
Blue Monday drives customers to rent more drama movies.
Is that John Ible from Tomolive?
Bigger.
Mints are nasty.
But I'm covered in pure chocolate.
I'm covered in pure chocolate.
You're gonna make me Blue Monday.
Blue Monday.
If you've never tried a junior mint in...
It's so good!
I promise.
Also, if you don't like mint, then your breath is probably
smelly.
What do you brush your teeth with?
Mint is precious and loved and our favorite.
You think so?
Really?
Your favorite?
Don't lie to me.
I should get mint.
Yeah!
I kind of want some junior mints now, too.
I haven't checked if we had any things to claim.
It doesn't look like it, though.
But new release on Tuesday.
And also the tape dealer.
Come me, Santo!
Santo is visiting the town plaza, and people are lining up
for their holiday family photo.
spike in popularity.
Man, Minky is pressuring us to buy snacks.
I would never, I would never, I would never, I would never.
Do you think he's been working while I've been staring at
this?
Okay, let's see.
I would eat Minto.
Don't do that.
Chocolate and Minto are a perfect pair.
Exactly!
Is he just that slow?
I can't tell.
Oh my gosh.
Pick up the pace, buddy.
We got a business to run.
Dang, everybody's reserving the galactic.
Sakamito ice ice ice.
Sci-fi.
Science fiction.
Oh.
Soon we'll be able to sell a lot of these, luckily.
There's a one movie at a time.
Don't we all?
All of our horror movies that were That were rented out are
back I freaking love Star Wars I freaking love Star Wars 99
minutes minutes to cannibalism I didn't bring up
cannibalism.
Oh, sorry.
The last dinosaur
Chocomito Girl Scout sponsorship then mint cookies win
But if you call him a thin mint, it just ain't true.
I'm kidding.
I take all the mint the other guy once.
Yeah!
I give it to you.
Oh, drama.
Next.
Swimmer in good hands!
Christmas.
Oh, Christmas.
Okay.
I signed you to check out.
I think people who say that mint candies taste like
toothpaste should stop eating toothpaste.
Agreed.
Alright.
Oh, that's not it.
Everybody, come one, come all!
Hmm.
Everybody is interested in...
Oh, in movies now.
Become interested in movies, beam!
Hmm.
Well, your twin is gonna kill you.
Your doppelganger is right behind you, and you know what
that means.
If you meet your doppelganger, you die.
Galactic Rebellion?
Sure thing.
There you go.
One copy of Hot Dog in Space 2 fully franked.
Oh, sounds awesome.
I just want to let you know, I'll be late returning my
movies.
Since I'm calling ahead, is there any chance you could wave
the late feed?
No.
Stop bothering me.
Yes, sir.
The fighting fish.
This one's really good.
Is that what happened to me?
No, no, no.
No.
What did you get?
My twin.
I feel like, why are you following me?
My VCR died and I refused to replace it.
Something tells me the VHS tapes won't be around for much
longer.
Just a feeling.
Do you want my tape collection?
Whatever could give you that idea.
VHS is forever!
Yeah, give me all your movies.
What do you got?
We have the explosive.
family tree.
One queen away.
The medicine test subject.
Wow, so interesting.
The dentist in the... Okay, that is a horror movie.
A dentist in the dark.
Why doesn't anyone ever donate their adult movies?
Because they know they have value.
VHS killed the radio star.
Oh.
VHS VHS killed the radio store.
You doing it?
I love the basket for...
Wait, is this from yesterday?
Oh my gosh, Ryan?
Why don't you clean up?
VHS killed the radio store.
Oh.
Oh, one second.
Oh, action.
Quisimus.
Hoorah.
Not in his job description.
To clean!
Actually, I don't think it is.
Galactic Rebellion.
Yes, sir.
In my mind and in my soul.
No place to play Viennese except in my store.
Oh, keeping my gun machine oiled up.
He brought it back.
Everyone walks out with such sass.
They really do.
They're so like, yeah, I got a great movie.
Drama, drama, drama.
These days, it's just drama, drama, drama.
It was a classic.
It was for their class.
I hope they got an A.
I hope the teacher reckons.
The lady in my pants was already rented, you guys.
The frying pan in the velvet room.
Who ordered the hot T-Rex?
I wonder what the skews are for those.
for the Minto movies.
They never donate those ones because they never get old.
They watch them until they break.
Did you have this video already?
Streamlabs.
Why is that your name?
Let's see.
I think you typed it in wrong.
I don't have it.
I think it does if you don't put your name in.
Oh, you become John Streamlabs.
That's crazy.
There you go.
A good... I'm in a rush.
I'm just looking for a good movie to rent.
Do you have one in mind?
Sure, Alice.
If you break this, I will come to your house.
I know... Alice, I will not forget.
Thank you, thank you!
Hey.
Hey?
SKU SKU SKU SKU What does SKU stand for?
Oh Oh gosh, wait, hold on I've said this before But if you
want to send me SKUs It's so much easier if you send us a
Streamlabs because then I can actually See them Sometimes
the chat goes too fast.
Stock keeping unit.
Oh!
Oh, yes!
Gus, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Let's check what we got.
Sorry, so much happened at the beginning of the stream.
The sausage rock star!
Why is it so expensive?
Hold on, let's see what the other ones are.
Oh, wait, we have my ghost's only regret.
Nice.
Good choice, good choice.
Oh.
Uh.
The Demented T-Rex.
That's a good one, that's a good one.
Hungry for Grandpa!
Thank you guys, thank you!
Nice.
Put him on, uh, return station.
What a jacket.
Hmm.
um oh today's tuesday so let's go out i think oh no just
kidding it's not tuesday it's sunday cannibalism at 107 just
because of the grandpa that grandpa get us get us how is can
it cannibalism can't be mentioned that that often no is it
yeah we're rolling in money we should get some more
decorations or something let's get um i
mean i could use another shelf now we'll go for decorations
decorations uh balloons let's do let's get some more neon
signs wait what do we have a big one oh we have a popcorn
over here we have a couple small ones Cash for a space
upgrade, you're right.
Oh, so stinking close.
Wait.
Oh, tomorrow.
We can.
Tomorrow.
We can upgrade.
Holy cow.
Yeah, we'll save up.
We get the altar room.
Don't call it that.
I mean, he can.
Hmm.
I think F needs to be the adult section.
This one is too small.
C will be our adult section.
F will be the arcade.
Our place is going to be huge, Ryan.
Alright.
Lights are out.
Have a good night.
Next.
What?
Oh.
Is this snow?
No.
Is it ice?
I can't actually tell.
Wait, what's wrong, Ryan?
What's the... Why are you so sad?
Ryan, why?
Ryan, don't be so sad.
Is it because you're getting put to work immediately?
Maybe frost?
Maybe.
I did type it wrong.
Let's try it.
We do have the hot dog in my fantasy.
Yes, we do!
That's a great one.
Uh-oh.
Ryan was wrong.
I think I caught something and I don't want to get anyone
else sick.
I need the day off.
Ryan!
Let him rest.
See you tomorrow!
Oh, I don't think we're going to be able to upgrade today.
Okay, we're turning off money.
Or, I mean, we're turning off...
We're...
We're turning off lights to conserve money.
That's what I was trying to say.
We're not turning off money.
That's what we need the most is, actually.
Oh, soon we get a new movie genre!
At level 20, you get a second staff member.
Holy cow!
A well-decorated and fully equipped store attracts more
customers.
Well, I think ours is pretty nice looking so far.
We could afford, like, another thing here or something.
But so far, I think we're doing pretty well for ourselves.
Oh my gosh, I have to do all of these myself.
Oops.
I need to turn off money to save the lights.
Yeah.
You guys know what I meant.
Don't act like you're better than me.
Don't act like you've never made a speaking mistake.
mistake ever before in your lives.
Wait.
Fantasy.
Typo in the group chat.
Everyone point and laugh.
Hmm.
Horror.
Action.
Oh, wait.
Oh wait, I messed that up.
Uh, shoot, which one was it?
I get confused with the colors.
Oh, here we go.
This one's drama.
Action.
Okay.
Noise.
Minor spelling mistake.
Okay, well today we won't make so much money.
That's alright.
We'll just do our best.
That's all we can do.
I am a humble small business you know like I I am I guess I
wait I said I best I get her four times are you okay that
might be pretty bad okay wait
are these not new releases anymore oh oh oh Once you extend
your store, my advice is to hire someone else, in my
opinion.
Oh, I cannot.
Because you have to be level...
You have to be level high.
Twentief to do that.
Unfortunately.
I actually cannot.
We could fire Ryan and just grab somebody else.
You know?
We could say, you know what?
You have been great, but no sick days.
Konichiwa-wagwan.
Thank you.
Konichi-wagwan.
Maybe is there a way to farm XP?
I don't know, actually.
That's a good question.
God, we'll be making money through this, though.
All these movies on clearance.
Nice.
How much is it actually to buy these?
Because if we bought some more and then put them on
clearance, we could make a small...
Oh, here's a...
15 random movies.
Fast fairy pursuit.
Break up over the foot.
Whispers of the cursed performer.
The apes king leave.
this hmm I'm seeing nothing all right let's just it's just
us today team let's do our best it's just us today team
already yeah hmm hold on
swimmer in good hands.
Dang, this one's popular.
Alright, did you request swimmer and okay, Hub's gonna say,
I have the movie Psycho Killer Foot reserved.
Yes.
There you are.
Hello.
Two of them?
Why?
Amount due.
There you go.
Oh, there you go.
I don't remember how to do this.
Wait.
Uh.
there you go hmm
thank you amount dude why $46
thank you one second galactic rebellion okay you're free to
go yes I love Christmas and I refuse to wait for the
holidays give me your favorite it is the holidays give me
your favorite Christmas movie please also if it's an old
movie That would be a nice bonus.
I tend to appreciate those more.
Here we go.
Christmas Eve with my letter.
First pick.
Ryan, I miss you.
Ryan.
I miss you.
I don't know how to count.
Die hard.
Is Die Hard considered a...
An old movie now?
Ryan can get a raise if he asks for it, but he needs to ask.
Thank you, you're free to go.
Willy Wonka over there.
It is.
You're free to go.
Can I have a raise?
Is your name Ryan?
I think your name is the Krunkster.
That doesn't sound like a Ryan to me.
150.
You're free to go.
It's nearly 40 years old now!
It is!
Wait, I've never done popcorn before.
Whoa!
Oh, oh geez.
There you go.
Five dollars even, you're free to go.
40 years is crazy.
It came out in 88.
Dang!
Julian, my best customer over here.
Thank you very much.
Yes?
Swimmer- Yes.
Now this movie should be in good hands.
Hope you're having a great week so far, Minto.
Joby Bear!
Oh my gosh!
You too!
Thank you!
Turns to dust.
The 80s were a long time ago.
Don't think about it.
The 80s don't exist.
Don't think about it, everybody.
You're afraid to go.
What is this?
Oh, it's candy!
Oh!
I thought it was...
I thought it was like a bootleg movie or something.
Dang!
God is my best customer.
You're free to go?
Yeah, it was the Mint's.
Galactic Rebellion.
Yes, yes.
Oh, we have nobody in our store.
Uh-oh.
We're failing as a business?
Please, please become obsessed with movies.
And become obsessed with Minto.
Become obsessed with Minto.
You'll want to come to her store every day and rent a movie.
Yes.
You love, you love.
Junior Mintz!
Minto world domination.
Yeah!
Exactly.
No, please.
Please, somebody.
Hello.
Vengeful ghost.
How do you know, babe?
See, he's obsessed, and that's why he got that movie.
Rent a minto?
that's kind of crazy asking that do you know what you're
asking that's kind of crazy
oh one queen away we got that for free what if this is the
guy that donated his movies and he's like I missed it so
much please I need to watch it one more time hello just one
movie are you Are you sure, Florence?
Sometimes they're, like, so aggressive about it.
But he doesn't have a VCR.
That's right, it broke!
No, he's just gonna pretend, like, he's gonna imagine it,
you know, like.
And in this part, I remember this thing happened.
Okay, but the color of the cotton candy doesn't matter.
It's just sugar.
They both taste the same, mister.
Boos!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the... for the 20 gifted!
Yes?
I was on a date last night and it was so awkward.
Do you have a romance movie to make me feel better?
Kissing my organ in the sky.
I mean,
I don't think that cotton candies can happen.
different tastes, right?
Blue is a flavor.
Holy cow.
See, I told you this guy is obsessed with me.
Emmett.
Emmett, I'll remember you.
He gets the vengeful ghost and he buys out my whole stock.
First off, thank you so much.
Thank you.
Dang, these movies are going crazy.
Everybody wants the Galactic Rebellion.
Five minutes.
dollars.
Says himself, thank you!
So much for the 20 gifted.
Yeah, I know it's not Christmas yet.
Who cares?
Do you have a Christmas movie to recommend?
By the way, I have a soft spot for bad movies.
I find them so entertaining.
No, well, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
Actually, for your memberships, I think it was memberships.
YouTube was like, hey, we're updating pricing to reflect
something something it's not so snap thank you it starts
like a beginning of the beginning of June I think but they
were like if you want to it's only for certain certain
countries so they were like you can have it start now or you
You could have it start June 1st.
So depending on your country, June 1st, some of the
memberships, not even just for my channel, for all channels,
might go up.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
My return was late.
I had a family emergency.
We lost our goldfish and movies were the last thing on my
mind.
Aww.
No sympathy.
Nah.
They also up the cost of premium?
They did?
No way.
But yeah.
I might make like a lower tier or something.
Maybe for people that just want to use emotes.
Yuzzo!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I might make one lower if you do want to switch.
Because I try to do membership streams or like post little
like...
things that I'm working on or something.
I'll be there today.
Lonely inmate?
Okay.
Are you actually gonna come?
Hmm.
But yeah.
I think you can do lower.
I think you can do like 99 cents or something.
Like a dollar.
Pretty sure.
Paid!
What?
I don't know if you saw the standy, but Oshia Plink and the
Density Concert was a lot of fun.
Of course I saw!
Of course!
Actually, I was watching you watch the Oregon Trail Beasties
panel.
Some SKUs.
Thank you!
Raymark, thank you so much for that.
Thank you.
Yeah, you can do it 99 cents.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, let's check out some SKUs.
Let's see.
3, 8, 9, 1.
A little reindeer's fast food.
Wait, it's so expensive.
The dinosaur graveyard!
Okay, I'll get that one.
The waitress not gonna have midnight.
Vampire hot dog!
Okay, it's kind of expensive, but I gotta get it.
Oh my goodness, I cannot type today.
The hot dog test subject.
Hold on.
The hat, the declaration of love.
Why are these also expensive?
The sausage spellcaster!
That one is a buy, a buy.
Naughty bomb.
Wait, Calmo, did I...
I looked up yours, right?
Okay.
Can we expand?
We can.
We can still expand.
hand.
Wait, how did this become mixed?
Blazing I-Booze!
It'll be flying off the shelves.
Action.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, we'll do these in the morning once we have Ryan back.
Should we up a little bit more which which expansion should
we do new movie release today oh like we could do a right
now but i'm thinking d would be better right do we save up
for d yeah these are modded in they're modded in a is bigger
oh that's true true it's just we would have to my only thing
is is if we wanted these two F E and F we get them sooner
you know what I mean because if we get a then we would have
to get D and then E and F not
sure yet it feels better for the layout that's true you need
a for the big one yeah okay We'll get A.
Whoa!
Dusty.
Oh my gosh.
My stuff is...
Us eye boosts started just like Jackie Chan.
Money for the new release.
Do I try it?
I have $13 left.
No!
Die, try!
Uh-oh.
I messed up everybody.
Everybody, I made a dire mistake.
I forgot about the new movie.
Oopsie.
Um, shoot.
Uh, hmm.
What do we do?
I don't think there's much we can do.
Restart the day?
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Play.
It's probably fine.
Oh, we're fine!
Everything is fine!
Okay, we're fine.
Tub space dust.
Yes, of course.
Look at it!
He's all chipper.
Everything's great.
Okay, now let's go buy a bunch of movies.
No!
I wanted it!
We'll get, like, what, 20?
Oh, no.
What?
Hey, so, um, this is awkward, but, uh, I think I deserve a
$5 raise.
How much are we spending on this guy at the moment?
Hold on a second.
How much are you worth?
$58 a day!
His stats are average.
He just has good trades.
Like, Brittany is good at checkout.
Yeah, Ryan is a greedy guy.
Right after taking a sick day.
I know!
You said you'd give him a raise if he asked.
I did say that, didn't I?
There used to be more employees that you could, or
applicants that you could hire.
There used to be, there used to be four.
I'm almost positive.
Hello, sweetheart.
It's grandma calling.
I wanted to give you $15 to help with your business.
Hope everything is going well.
I'm very proud of you.
We don't accept donations at the store.
Thank you, grandma.
Grandma.
Nice.
I love that we just talked about Die Hard and now we just
got Die Trying.
Getting died trying during the holidays?
It's poetic.
All right.
What?
What are you staring at?
I can't find any empty science fiction or...
Oh, no, no, no, no, buddy.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Ryan, stop it.
Keep...
Get back to work.
My goodness.
Gracious.
Oh, that's because he put all of these up!
Oh, okay, I see what's happening now.
I see what's happening now.
No, Ryan.
These are for sale.
These are for sale now, Ryan.
We'll put one of them on here.
Okay.
There we go.
The jump skip.
I wish he would at least like your you know what you asked
for a raise Work faster Sorry about this he says Come on man
Come on
He looks so distressed I know Poor guy Oh Nice Nice
There.
Yippee-kaye!
Yippee-ki-ye!
Yippee!
I'm not working him to the bone!
Look, he's happy.
And he's just...
He's strutting around.
Like the good employee that he is.
Alright.
Tomorrow we will upgrade.
Big promise.
But we got our new movie today.
And...
We'll get some more shelves and stuff too.
Maybe lots of adult films.
Maybe that one?
That area is kind of nice though.
What if it is the adult room?
Poor guy.
She's working him too much.
No!
Do we still have the I-Book movie?
The what?
What's that one?
harsh mistress.
He asked for a raise.
Then he has to work according to the raise.
Oh, the I-boo movie!
I was like, wait, what?
Yeah, we do.
Blazing I-boo's.
Might not be in such demand.
That's okay, though.
It just got on the shelves.
Here, we'll organize a little bit.
Don't feel bad.
My time will come.
One day somebody will see your greatness.
It'll be like a la-la land moment.
You know, you'll do your stage play and there will be
someone in the crowd being like, yeah.
That one is a diamond in the rough.
But instead they'll watch your porno and think the same
thing.
It will be a cult classic.
People will go to movie theaters and throw soap.
spoons at the screen for your movie.
City of stars.
Why are they shining just for me?
Air in the bar.
And the parking lots.
Ryan, are you old enough to handle adult films.
I actually don't know.
The people love the swimmer in good hands.
Who heard of the Hot T-Rex is back?
Wait.
Let me handle these, buddy.
I sure hope he is.
I sure hope he's old enough.
Dang, our place is so stocked.
It's kind of crazy.
Crazy.
Drama.
All right.
I feel like it was much faster when it was just me doing it.
Is that, is that me?
Oh, he's just helping a little bit.
Okay.
All right, Ryan.
Table for two with our T-Rex.
Okay.
All right, buddy.
Assign a job.
Check out.
There you go.
Okay.
We are open for business.
Oh.
Open for business.
He asked for one raise, and he started getting violent i saw
red i'm sorry you know oh i'm you know times are tough and
i'm a small business owner i can only do what i could do
hello they will come for the heirloom wait you didn't
reserve it i reserved a copy wait you did Oh, I'm blind.
There you go.
I'm here to check out the cute ghost girl handing out
flyers.
It's like I'm an idol, like being like, please come to our
live.
Please come to our show.
Please.
Ah.
Yeah.
Please.
Hey, y'all.
How's the business going?
It's booming.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, take responsibility.
It's booming.
Where's all my customers?
Wait, how is this mixed?
What did I...
I don't see fantasy.
What did I accidentally put?
um oh sci-fi my bud one moment please
explain the joke uh uh i'm a ghost and i say i i say boo and
then uh the business is uh is is uh booming Did I try?
Wait, you didn't reserve it.
Did you?
You get it?
Why do ghosts say boo?
Why?
Wait, what just happened?
Why do...
Why?
Why do dogs pee with one leg up?
Ryan's getting bullied today.
Oh, did she just wink at me?
Hello.
The monstrous shipment.
There you go.
To get to the other side.
Duh.
Exactly.
Purr.
You love movies.
Yes.
I love hypnosis.
It always works.
You love movies, you love movies, you love movies, you love
movies, you love movies, you love movies.
Dang it!
I need to re-watch the VHS how to hypnotize the audience.
Philosophical.
I suppose it's their...
It's in their nature?
The lonely inmate?
Oh.
Starting to think about movies.
Enter the inside of her head for extra efficiency.
Exactly, you understand.
Wait, that guy, he definitely loves movies.
You love movies, you love movies, you love movies.
You love movies.
When's this place getting laser disc?
I mean, come on.
VHS or the future?
Is that what saying boo is?
What are you doing to us?
No, I was just asking a similar question.
Of course.
Obviously, you're asking, you're asking a ghost why they do
that in their nature is like asking a dog.
Why they do that in their nature?
The rocket man that followed you home.
A dog.
Why do you say it like that?
Why do you type it like that?
A dog.
Wait, buddy.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
It's like asking a cat why he says meow.
My cat doesn't say meow.
My cat chirps.
And I know cats that honk.
What about cats that honk?
Have you guys seen those?
a cat that go like hound instead of meowing oh yacht power
up oh those are geese in disguise that's an airplane I got a
cat that chirps oh my gosh pause is a absolute chirper she's
always that's all she does is chirping chirp chirp She's the
chirpiest girl.
Most cats can make a wide range of sounds and even able to
imitate many birds.
Yeah!
I like to help her out sometimes because she'll like...
Oh my gosh, today there was...
I heard him.
Today there was like the biggest squail and I heard her
go...
I heard her like trying to get at him.
And I was like trying to help her chirp at him.
I was like...
I'm trying to get him to cat-cat.
She goes, cat-cat.
I had a rough month and pinched penny is good now.
Oh, be funny.
I'm glad you're okay now.
Glad you're okay.
Extra large spell book, please.
Double swirl dome.
The appliance through space.
Let's just buy it.
Intergalactic buffalo endeavors.
A family waiting for Santa.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you for the skew.
One second.
Extra large spell block, please.
Double swirl, no.
I don't know about that one, chief.
Let's see.
This is a freaky movie.
I recognize the skew.
Wait.
Oh, my bad.
I'm so...
Thank you!
Wait.
We're just a little...
Because of that, we're just a little shy.
But that's okay.
It's worth...
Screw the new room.
Get the movie.
I'm organizing a Christmas theme party at work.
I need a Christmas movie to give me decoration ideas.
What do you propose?
By the way, my grandfather might watch it also when he likes
classic films.
An old movie would be better.
Okay, an old Christmas.
Oh, Santa's favorite sausage.
There you go.
Wow.
Oh, she's not done.
That one is going in the personal collection.
Oh, yeah.
This is so weird.
Did you see the hut?
Fill the new room.
Fill it with the shelf in the center.
Just the cat versus snake in it.
We can put posters of it all over the walls.
Oh, wow.
Thank you for getting so many.
Oh, Maya, I saw what you got even.
Don't worry.
I won't tell Grandpa.
Grandpa.
Have a good night!
Wait, that put us at the exact amount to upgrade.
We'll have 44 cents to our name, but...
But!
Should we?
Maybe it is for Grandpa.
She gets to have a good night, Nato.
You're free to go.
Wait, really like...
Wait, is your free to go?
Not something normal to say?
Also, wait, Gupple, I think yours, I just saw your stream
labs.
Let's see what it is.
Oh, it was just...
Gupple, thank you, too.
I didn't think the stream labs went through yet.
So this is how dogs and dinos die.
Not with DVD deliveries, but with Yowie.
I mean...
dinosaurs.
It was a big old meteor that went bang.
Not to call it the big bang, but you know what I mean?
Why is there...
Why is the ground chipping?
Is this winter?
Should I buy it?
But we can't do anything with it yet.
I could just move some stuff in there, but it's kind of
like...
As a cashier ever told you, you're free to go.
I don't know.
if you're with midwestern it's a normal thing to say because
we love imprisoning people they're constant last-minute
additions what wait one more day I think so too then such a
YouTube memberships are 99 USD and on and are on the new
channel exchange rate if you make a lower tier it'll be the
same when YouTube makes the change you're awesome wait FYI
for folks in the other areas for ideas of where you can Go
check the cost.
Yeah.
Oh, it just went through.
Thanks, Kapo.
Help.
Oh, yeah, Ryan.
He won't get paid.
That's so right.
You're right.
He won't get paid if we don't do it.
Thanks for putting those away, buddy.
Yeah, I will keep you on the return station for now.
Oh.
Oh, we got kids movies.
Oh, it's starting to look a little chilly.
Oh, it's snowing!
Brian, it's snowing!
Snow, snow, snow.
We need more snow.
We got, uh, let's do the thing where you get, uh, not new,
market.
The gargoyle during Christmas.
not cigarette in the high i don't think that's for kids
tome of the cursed cow juice
i don't think tango with my gangster that sounds like an
actual like novel i would read ta-da here's the bandit
Oh, no.
No.
I'm not feeling well.
I need to go home for the day.
Oh, Ryan!
What?
It was a different era.
Have a good Japanese class.
I just got the raise, too.
Fire him?
He's faking?
What if I... Let's say it's gonna be a busy day.
Erg, okay.
Oh, he got mad at me.
You guys think he's really faking?
I want to trust him.
The Infection's Lucky Day.
I don't think these are children's movies.
We'll make this one.
for kids for now i want to see what other movies we have as
well
different era magic coffin count with me
syringe with flying colors woman puzzle party
we got car in the hat so close magic coffin count with One
of these movies.
Like, some of them see it like the dentist animal bunch,
sure.
Bath on rollerblades.
Fishermen in Candyland, sure.
Doghouse on rollerblades.
Race car.
Why are there so many things on rollerblades?
But woman puzzle parties.
With the exclamation point.
It's so funny.
Now we have like all these cursed films.
I feel like I have to get the cigarette one.
Like convict and treat.
What the hell?
Cigarette in the hat.
It's so funny.
Yeah.
F them kids.
Oh it's so funny.
You doing okay there, Ryan?
You just seem to be staring into space and stuff.
Broken?
Two of them?
Oh my god.
Who is breaking my new movies?
You would totally have been a fan of Magic Cough.
It's true.
I really would have been.
Convict and Treats does not sound like a kids movie.
No, it doesn't.
Reserved.
Banned from the store.
Banned, banned, banned.
This will become mixed.
It will be drama and action.
Because I think those are the two that are kind of
overflowing at the moment.
Woman puzzle party is what we're calling the Portal 2 collab
with Mickey.
We were supposed to do this.
it before like we were supposed to do it recently but we'll
do it we'll do it once i'm back for sure tomorrow is santa
okay tomorrow is santa i will buy a new shelf
a big one but i don't have anywhere to put it oh no that's
not true i do well I'll hold off for a second I couldn't get
like I can move that I'll hold off because it's fine for now
it's fine for now such a cute store thank you
are you cold chilly day I'm shivering we should give Ryan a
jacket and a You don't have to always be...
Look at this.
This is terrible.
I have to order two more.
Ryan working 16 hours a day, 7 days a week.
Hey.
He knew what he was...
I told him it was that was worth the hours.
He gets paid well.
He gets paid great.
That's why he's always sick.
No, it's the weather.
It's the weather.
What other applicants do we have?
The only thing is Ryan has energetic and strong bladder.
Like he does not fall asleep.
He does not take bathroom breaks.
We need someone kind of similar.
Freakout 60.
But look at this.
This guy is 37.
He's good at checkout.
No break perk is nice.
I know.
Apparently they can fall asleep!
I guess you have to like kind of, I don't know, wake them up
or something.
Go with loyal and immune.
Maiden Mint does the ordering, she does the cleaning.
Yeah, I had to clean up the cotton candy that Ryan left out
after I gave him a snack.
Are you done with these yet?
Almost?
You're so close.
Very good, Ryan.
Very good.
All right.
Is there an immune?
Is that just...
Oh.
It's okay.
I'll find it.
Give it to me.
Oh, God.
He's terrified.
Go back to the checkout.
Let me handle it.
Let me handle this.
Sometimes he gets a little in over his head, you know.
Sure.
Not the rooster and sausage, please put some respect.
Whoa.
Game?
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, uh, oh my mouse just died!
One second.
It was telling me earlier that it needed to be charged.
It was telling me earlier it needed to be charged.
She lives, she lives.
Why did I start climbing those shelves?
How did that happen?
Ryan, why do you put things on shelves like that?
Why do you do that, actually?
But also, why don't you put it over here?
Ryan, I have many questions.
I have many, many questions.
Our horror section is, like, nearly stocked.
Completely.
Everything is basically nearly stocked.
stocked completely oh people are buying out the junior mince
they're going crazy our our choice in snack is like superior
absolutely the best okay open hello hello
Yes, the best tastes.
Can I speak to Joseph?
Yes.
Oh.
Waldo.
We found him!
Don't leave, don't leave, don't leave.
Nice.
Can I speak to Joe?
Joe Mama!
got him no don't leave see we we convinced her the jiggle
physics on some of these characters is kind of insane I'm
not gonna lie it's a little distracting to me hmm I am but a
simple ghost die trying you reserved it ah really are you
lying you always were a kidder me though if there are junior
mince's That implied the existence of senior mince.
Well, I'm forever 19, so...
Hey.
The ghost, a Christmas legend.
Merry Christmas.
Permament.
That's more likely.
Tis the season to the...
Jolly.
La la la la.
La la la.
The foot during Christmas night.
Cake Starship sounds awesome.
Forever 19 Season X?
I mean...
Who's counting?
You're not counting, right?
Feel my nose!
Why would you be counting, huh?
Hold on, sorry.
I'm trying to move the wire for the mouse.
No!
What part of forever?
Don't you understand?
Yeah.
How many times do I have to teach you this lesson, old man?
What did we get?
Whoa!
Oh.
Okay.
The elf's wrong number.
So the next time you misspeak, it will be because you're
having a senior...
No!
I'm not a senior!
If I am, I'm missing out on my discounts and I'm getting
scammed!
The medicine test subject.
Of course, of course.
Yeah!
What the heck?
Ryan, I'm bored.
There's not enough people on the streets.
It's cold.
Nobody wants to go outside.
Wow.
Nobody wears coats either.
These people are crazy.
I died trying.
Why won't anybody come to my store?
Beanies are all they need.
We love Hagmint.
19 is too old for people nowadays, I guess.
Alright, Leonardo DiCaprio.
Nope.
Thank you.
We need internet ads!
Yeah, but like dial up is just so slow.
Nobody will... Nobody will be able to see them.
Oh, hello.
What can I help you with?
Oh, you reserved die trying, yeah?
This one?
This is the one you want?
Yeah?
Trying
to throw it in his face.
Not because I don't like him.
I'm just feeling a little...
I'm just feeling away today.
Like this.
No, I didn't mean to hit you!
Wait, what happened?
Oh.
Wow, you're so sturdy.
Nobody's getting the kids movies.
People hate them.
It's because we don't have kids coming in here.
We only have adults and adult movies.
I will never buy any more kids movies.
Well, what else?
What are the kids movies we got?
wait I forgot this is the same day puzzle girl oh women
women puzzle party women puzzle party it's the only thing
that got rented does the I blue still have collision physics
of the suit of armor no I think he has I think he has those
physics of I blue sorry but you have a way too many movies
to choose from can you help me pick just give me a good one
I'd enjoy your recommendation even more if he gave me a kid
film.
Our best movie was already rented.
I'm sorry, sir.
Magic coffin is a good one.
Give him the tobacco one.
It wasn't good enough.
Hey.
Tub space dust.
Wait a second.
Isn't this the person that was just like, I'm going to come
today.
Put it on the shelf.
Please.
Okay.
You got this, Ryan?
He's really tired.
His head is starting to split into two.
How many more before we get the cell?
There's, like, cell 20 popcorns.
We haven't even sold 20 popcorns?
That's pretty bad, no?
Like...
Is there anything higher to employees?
Like, you can't get that.
Unlock all stories, man.
Again, I'm in the...
Unlock all movies.
genres.
Buy an arcade machine.
Own 500 movies in your inventory.
Own 1000 movies.
Oh yeah, I can get the expansion.
Yeah.
Please excuse our dust.
Oh, yeah.
I've been trying.
I've been waiting for the release of Die Trying.
Oh, you're lucky.
You're very lucky.
I wonder what's our stats now How can we check?
Oh, data here maybe?
Uh, no Store value is $5,195 So we're about halfway To the
10,000
But I wish we could see how many popcorns we have What?
What's your issue?
Oh, please I'm not talking to you Yes?
I have a broken fee?
Oh, I'm charging.
And stay out!
Yeah!
Never come back!
The disrespect.
Are you okay, Ryan?
Did she hurt you?
Even after I got die trying for her.
You know what?
She doesn't deserve to rent it, so it's perfectly fine.
Other people will rent it because it's our newest move.
I need you to do the return station again.
While I move stuff around.
Hmm.
100% justified.
Thank you.
I do feel justified in that.
Yeah, I do.
I do.
Let's see.
Let's put our dramas down here, I guess.
Because we have room for that down here.
Um.
Hmm.
Were his eyes going different ways?
Never mind.
Just keep working, buddy.
Whoa!
Our movie!
Our posters are floating.
He is sick.
You're right.
He's sick in the head.
Hmm.
Oh, it's kind of awesome.
Watch it.
You, like, go underneath the signs for, like, this special
area.
Oh yeah this will become our massive massive 18 plus section
massive it'll be the whole walls mark my words why is it so
dark in that room I mean it's it's you know it's just how
it's got to be A letter to my breakfast.
Oh, dang, that one's kind of popular.
Just keep going.
Oh, you're done.
Good job.
Uh, never mind.
We'll do the rest tomorrow so that he can put away the rest
of the boobies.
Sell 20 popcorns!
We did it!
It happened!
I was just complaining.
Santa!
Stay back or I will intervene.
Oh my god.
I asked Santa for a new VHS player.
I can't believe it's really him.
Santa.
They're not doing shit.
Yeah, you're on my property.
Santa doesn't pay me enough for this.
I get him.
Santa's really skinny, huh?
He's just like wearing...
regular pants wait his top his tops and his bottoms don't
match Santa this is like oh the people being like I can't
believe it's really him oh my gosh solid snake I mean not
solid snake naked snake it's really you you can tell I'm
because I mix that up.
Alright.
Yes.
No, that is not solid snake.
Okay.
Yes.
The ultimate bone zone.
Santa meet and greet.
What should we say?
Um, you should say...
How...
You should ask what the threshold is to get on the naughty
list.
Because, like, if it's, like, not even that bad, then just
go for it.
You know what I mean?
Like, don't even care.
That's my philosophy.
Ooh, fancy.
Feed the man a tree frog.
Just asking that puts you on the list?
Which list?
It puts you on A list, maybe.
nice oh wait oh i forgot the oh actually it's fine it gives
a little bit of character like see this one is
wait wait why is this one have that oh weird never mind like
see there's these ones have this kind of a wall but the rest
it wouldn't let me do that for those ones so strange We're
getting a whole upgrade.
Ooh, I like it.
It's okay, I often get mistaken with that.
Sorry, Snallid.
Sorry, Snallid Snake.
Hmm.
We can.
Uh...
What if I made like a maze of frames?
That'd be so good.
Hmm.
Movie display.
More neon signs.
I can't get the big one.
We could get the ceiling sign.
Or we could get another eye blue!
Yeah.
I want that good.
I want this guy.
Our best customer.
Yippee!
Are you almost done with these?
Oh, our shelf is almost completely full.
Oh, wait, I just had it.
I just had it.
I had it.
You?
I just had it.
Oh, didn't I pick up two?
Okay, just kidding.
Safa.
Why are we looking at the adult section?
I don't know.
There might be something good there.
There might be like a hidden gem, you know?
I don't know.
You have to look.
Alright!
Good job, Ryan!
Let's organize our stuff a little bit.
Are we ready for another great day?
You are at checkout.
And I am gonna pull in these poor suckers.
Oh.
Just kidding.
I'm ready!
Oh, come on, people.
Can I pick that up?
So sorry.
This person, for sure.
Little elf.
Oh.
Nice.
I'm ready!
I'm ready for a gro- I'm starting to get sleepy though.
This?
Die trying?
Here you are.
Look, we can now see who the real freaks are.
I'm calling to complain.
I rented a movie and it was only rewound halfway.
It's not a big deal, but could you please do your job
correctly?
Not my problem.
I missed the part where there's my problem.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
Come on, come on.
It's starting to snow.
Please, you'll warm yourself up in my little, in my humble
video rental store.
We have heat.
You'll feel the heat in our adult section!
My kid's skipping school because she's sick.
I want to make her feel better and rent a kid movie to
watch.
Any suggestions?
Bonus if you can recommend an old movie.
Recent movies are all the same in my opinion.
She's not skipping school.
She's missing school.
The- This one's perfect!
The infection's lucky day!
Oh.
Perfect.
Hmm.
What?
That's like, that was three people in a row that hated me.
Hmm.
Four!
Correct me if I'm wrong, but didn't you say you had a
meeting scheduled for later?
Yeah.
In an hour.
I probably should go soon.
We'll go at the end of this day.
This will be our last day.
Wait, what's up?
Never mind.
I thought I was being told something.
Yes, everybody.
Oh.
Wednesday, Densetsu.exe idle meeting.
Yeah, actually.
That's exactly what it is.
Wow.
Steiner just like steals it.
He takes us away from you all.
See, you guys can't say that Steiner that you like him
because he is separate.
We could be together and be streaming forever and ever and
ever and have so much fun.
But he says, no, we must have a meeting.
His greed sickens me.
Me too!
Die Tryin.
Oh, you did reserve that.
Yes, yes, what is it?
They came for the werewolf!
I have it!
Another Die Tryin was broken!
in what is with this movie people need maybe they do need to
ask of santa for a new vhs player like what the heck hey you
hey you wait did i sorry i'll pass why give me a reason for
your rejection fill out this form oh nice creeper shirt okay
never mind i hate it what the where'd that come from um
The movie rewound, but die trying.
Oh.
Minus two.
Yes.
I'm in the mood for a good old revenge story with crazy
fight scenes.
What action movie should I watch?
You should watch Explosive Stepbrother.
It's crazy.
Oh.
Screaming.
The dentist's in good hands!
Oh.
Oh my gosh, this is like one of our most popular movies.
We can't have it out there.
My name is on...
Letter to my breakfast, yes.
Yeah.
Did you throw it at that lady?
No, no, I threw some sci-fi movie at her that we definitely
got back, so...
What's the point of having these people in line for Santa?
They've been waiting all day.
Okay.
Can we give Santa a flyer?
Let's try.
Uh-oh.
We have emergencies happening.
Yes?
They came for the werewolf.
Oh.
Uh, you over here?
Yes.
Did I try?
Uh, we have none left.
Sorry.
I cannot help you.
Oh, wait.
I could have bought some more, couldn't I have.
My bad.
Well, I could buy some more.
Actually, I think I need to buy one anyway.
Alright, you guys, fight for it!
Fight for it!
I have one left!
Yeah, yeah, it's right there.
No, you're stupid!
The movie was working fine when I dropped...
Oh, no, I'm...
Oh.
Is it Thursday?
Yes, it is.
is what do we got you're not another undercover cop right we
have dripping on the mammoth who ordered the hot tentacle oh
page thank you oh my goodness oh also corona thank you for
the sorry i missed your age appropriate kids movies hot
tentacle the bandit love affair Keyboard freak show.
That's just you guys.
Thank you.
Client is asking to see a manager.
What the?
Why?
One moment, one moment.
I'll be there in a second.
Catching strays.
No, moving with, no, charging.
Yeah.
Give me the money.
Oh, hello again.
Lonely inmate.
There it is.
Wow.
Boy.
Uh, what was I gonna do?
I can't remember.
We went to go buy these movies and my head went blank.
Die trying?
Do we have it?
No, someone took it.
Sorry.
Oh, the SKUs!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I was like, something I had to do.
One, two, three, two, four, three, three.
Math party with my dynamite.
I do like that one.
Sugar rush syringe!
Okay, that one's really good.
And not so expensive.
One, two, one, eight, one, nine, four, one.
Virus on wheels, yeah.
Yeah.
The smoke and the little duck.
It has zero stars.
It's a literal flop.
Oh, magicians, trusty T-Rex!
Thank you, Corona.
And thank you, Paige.
Ta-da!
Here's the outsider.
Why is it so expensive?
Cow juice and treats.
Eww!
Sugar Rush T-Rex!
And it's such a spooky price even!
Wait, which one was it?
Treasure in the box.
Nice.
The T-Rex in the little duck!
The woman in the sky!
Why does that sound like an actual thing?
Oh, oh, oh, you're still checking them out.
Dang, they're taking a long time.
Good haul, everybody, good haul.
I'll do this while...
Nice.
Woman puzzle party!
It came back!
It is literally midnight and there are people waiting for
Santa.
Hmm.
Santa, Santa's working overtime.
Crazy.
Nuclear smoke warfare.
Sounds awesome.
Woman puzzle party.
It's so good.
Magic coffin came back too.
Awesome.
Our store getting bigger is obviously great, but it's also
kind of a...
It's a bit of a hassle now, we have such a large area, you
know?
Uh, I'll do these ones, it's okay, probably.
No!
It's okay, we have our mixed shelf.
You gotta clone Ryan, actually...
Alright, return station to you.
but look at this one day this will be the most stupendous
amazing wait so when I open up the new expansion okay it's
gonna be it's gonna be this big area this is going to open
up okay nice okay okay if only it was it possible to hire
employees sadly that will not be invented until level 20
Yeah, we're only level 13.
And sadly, you know, level 20, it's like being...
You need to earn the respect.
It's like being a level 1 thug versus a level 20 mafia boss.
And the level 20 mafia boss is able to hire two staff.
Because we have the good rep.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Did we check what applicants we had today?
Energetic and loyal!
Lana is 52 and she's good at both.
Oh!
We have Dylan also.
Thick skin.
I don't know, I'm attached to Ryan, but also...
Ryan has been with you through thick and thin.
I know.
Oh, Ryan is $58.
And he's only average in both traits, in both skills.
I mean, he does have good traits, but Hana also has
energetic.
And she will never ask for a raise.
You need the VHS rental street credit.
She's cheaper and better.
Ryan needs to chase his dreams.
She will take a bathroom break.
Is Ryan wearing a diaper all day?
Now that I think about it.
Ryan, why do you never need to take a bathroom break?
Ryan, why won't you look at me when I'm talking to you?
Ryan, Ryan, say something.
Yes, boss.
Everybody keep working.
Why do you think he's always sick?
Does that explain the smell?
Happy holidays.
Oh, oh, oh, please wait in line.
One family at a time.
These elves, they run it like a, like a dang...
A, like, factory line.
It's times like this, you gotta ask yourself, Mint.
Is he a Reynolds or a Gosling?
I don't know.
Don't look at me like that.
What should I do?
Ibu of the wisdom.
I'm gonna put it to a vote.
We'll put it to an actual vote.
Start a poll.
Fire Ryan or keep Ryan?
Fire him.
Burn the witch.
Keep him.
Spare.
Spare him.
I will do what the people ask of me.
This is up to you and your crazy eyes.
Why are you guys bugging out like that?
Oof, this is hard.
How do you think I feel?
It's even harder for me.
I can't do it.
No, I can't do it.
Remember when Ryan sent a twin to cover him?
I remember because of the stash.
Wait a second, you're right.
Sometimes Ryan sends in, like, another Ryan.
It's, like, not him.
The pole is crazy.
I boost have a heart.
I don't know.
It's just business.
Anna will betray you!
Ryan's kind of says sometimes Can we really trust him?
I know
No one grows a stash that fast That's what I'm saying I wish
I could hire someone else I wish I could hire too But I
don't have the street cred Remember he asked for a raise on
his first day Was it him?
Alright Oh The pole even went up.
Goodbye, Ryan.
Please don't fire me.
I need this job.
Ryan.
This little town, you're bigger than it.
You have big dreams and big goals and big aspirations.
Like you're smiling again.
You're better than this town.
You're going to go out and you're going to do big, great
things, okay, Ryan.
The music is like It's giving me I'm getting deadly
premonition BGM here
Goodbye Ryan Goodbye
I'm going to hire Ana right now He didn't even like this job
What a loser Oh
There he goes.
This is your last chance to see Ryan, everybody.
Another day, another dollar, I always say.
Hey, Anna.
I'm ready to work.
Just tell me where you need me.
Uh, check out.
I'm on it.
Look at that.
Go get her.
She's cool as hell.
Yeah!
Generate $10,000 in total revenue!
Wait, I paid for both of them?
Oof, that sucks.
That's fine, though.
It's fine.
That's my girl!
Oh, what's wrong?
What happened to you?
Oh, geez.
What's...
Oh, now you're sad?
Why?
It's okay, I'm not gonna fire you.
She saw what I did to the last guy.
Ryan was taken from his job, neither truly alive.
What'd she say?
Anyway, we have some cash money we can get.
Oh no, wait, I did get the movies, didn't I?
Okay, good.
Claim and claim.
Yeah!
Oh, don't forget to end the poll, thank you.
and she didn't ask for a raise she's at her post wait I want
to see how good she is
oh speedy over here wow fired on Christmas it's not
Christmas it's Christmas season he was fired the day Santa
came Santa deemed him naughty naughty But anyways, guys, we
shall call it here for today.
Oh, I have a meeting in 30 minutes, so I gotta go get ready
for that.
I think it's in 30 minutes.
Wait, I'm gonna check and make sure that the video
processed, okay?
I'm scared.
Did it process?
Episode 3!
Oh, goody!
Good, good, good, good.
Okay, glad.
Okay, good, good, good.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the 2015!
Thank you for the stream, right now, after thinking about
it, you aren't senior meant you are superior meant!
Thank you so much!
I'm going to keep it at the peak!
Thank you so much, everybody!
Here.
Tell me!
Merlin!
Thank you so much for the peek!
Thanks very much, Rewind!
As well as the video editing and modding tutorials, of
course!
Have a nice trip and just letting you know that you're both
my favorite ghost and my favorite maid!
Am I your favorite mint?
Thanks for the stream, Minto!
Looking forward to dancing to collab!
Yeah!
Thank you, Taya, Dr. Papay!
Tell Steiner we won't forgive him.
I will let him know.
Thank you.
Rick and Dan, thank you so much for the peek.
Have a good Japan trip.
I've missed Pinto a normal amount.
A lot.
I will have a good trip.
I'll miss you guys.
Hopefully the auto feeder is good too.
Tim Stummy winning.
Phil, thank you.
Could you recommend a good sci-fi movie for me to watch?
Alien.
No getting sick this time.
no actually I had a dream last night and I was in Japan and
I went to an idle handshake event and I think I dreamt about
I think I dreamt about York's lighter because I was playing
with a lighter but like you know how some lighters have like
a little like you has like a button you press like you you
go you you slide down and you press the button I pressed
that and it like got jammed and so the lighter like wouldn't
go out and I was like oh my gosh the lighter's not going out
it's gonna cause a fire and where was I going with this oh
then I I left it in a corner in the of the building and I
went home and at home I got sniffles and I was like oh no
how could I be in Japan and get sick again no no no
I forgot, travel safe, stay healthy, thank you!
Thanks for the stream boss sending some good vibes.
Thanks for reminding us to rewind our VHS tapes.
It's not just rewind, it's a be kind.
You have to do the first part, it's the most important.
The be kind, not just to yourself, the others, but also to
yourself.
Yes, yes, yes.
yes be kind and then rewind i'll rewind my dvds too yes yes
yes yes thanks for this jv2 safe travels beat up steiner for
us how are you let me make sure when is my meaning
in 30 minutes yes and then rewind yeah but be kind and then
rewind dvr is off i can't rewind oh well uh again the be
kind is the more important part.
Travel safe, have fun, boss.
Thank you!
Thanks, Takizo.
Thank you.
If it's just a dream, your trip will be amazing.
Also, free of stuck lighters and stifles.
Dorygo, thank you.
Thanks for all the smiles.
I mean, don't you always cheer me up.
Thank you.
Thanks so much for a whole month.
Thanks for sticking around.
I'm starting to get thirsty because I have, oh wait, I do
have tea.
I wonder if my Da Vinci ever rendered.
Oh, Mexican, thank you.
Have a great trip, Vinci.
Sinaio, thank you.
Rafi, Rafael, thank you so much for the gift, dude.
Michael, thank you.
For a whole year.
12 months, let's go.
Thank you, thank you.
My voice is starting to get a little icky, though.
Thank you.
Thank you!
I see the other one too.
Camitos, I've traveled on your trip.
Thanks for always bringing smiles and energy to all our
stars.
God bless your activities.
Hope to see you soon.
I will be back soon.
I'll be back before you guys even know it.
And if you miss me at all, then you'll have the Wolf Among
Us that will be starting on Saturday.
But also, I will be on Denza 2 channel on Friday night.
It's a little bit late.
Sorry, but...
Salkin, thank you!
FaceTime, thank you!
Even leaving...
Even leaving us with the Minky Auto Feeder.
I try.
Sending vitamin C waves of good health.
Thank you, Thomas!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Minky-dim.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Oh, I can't sing Wheel on the bus.
I'll get copyright struck.
I'm missing Mint already.
Stay safe and...
Stay safe.
Stay safe and not sick.
The cupades, thank you.
Already missing Minky.
Do not miss Minky.
For Minky is always haunting you.
I'm always.
I'm always haunting you.
I'm always watching.
Yes.
So close to two years.
Thank you.
Do not miss a minke.
Thank you everybody.
I had fun.
I hope you had fun too.
I love this game.
It's so...
It's like something about it that's just so relaxing.
Just really...
Thank you!
Really just just just scratches that itch.
Thank you everyone!
Carvo, I see your Domo 2.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, everybody.
Thank you so much.
I'll see you when I get back.
Always watching.
Okay, I can explain earlier.
Yeah?
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
I will haunt you later.
I'll haunt you tonight and tomorrow.
And the next day and the next day and the next day and the
next day and the next day and the next day and the next day
and the next day and the next day and the next day and the
next day and the next day and the next day.
And the next day, and the next day, and the next day, and
the next
day, and the next day, and the next day, and the next day,
and the next day, and the next day, and the next day, and forever.